Speaker 1: So there's some pretty funny COVID
hijinx going on. This is not the most serious
thing, but it just shows how petty everybody
is. And to some degree, I kind of like it
in at least as far as Joe Biden is concerned, as
many of you know, Joe Biden recently had COVID and
there were some on the right. We covered Allison
Steinberg and some others who seemed sort of happy
that Joe Biden had COVID. They weren't straight
up saying, I hope he dies and doesn't recover,
but they certainly seem to be implying
it. And yesterday, President Joe Biden
returned to work, officially announced that he has
tested negative for COVID. His isolation can now
end and that it was mild all along.
Speaker 3: Hello everyone.
I have just tested negative
for COVID 19 after isolating for five days.
Speaker 1:
So those hoping for the demise of Joe Biden due
to COVID unfortunately will be disappointed.
But here's where it gets petty and kind of funny.
Joe Biden brought up. This is just so funny. It's
apropos of nothing. Biden contrasted his COVID
case where it was mild. He didn't need oxygen.
He didn't get helicoptered to Walter Reed for
fears that he would soon be unable to walk under
his own power. You might remember we later learned
that when Trump got COVID, suddenly there was
this announcement, Oh, he's being helicoptered to
Walter Reed. What's going on? And we later learned
that doctors and advisors came to him, and with
tears in their eyes, they said, Sir, you might
want to go to Walter Reed now, because the way
this is going, we may have to take you there in
a stretcher at some point. And Trump didn't want
the optics of that, so he flew to Walter Reed.
And Biden just kind of made fun of Trump, for lack
of a better term. That's really what he did here.
Speaker 3: Here's the bottom line. When my
predecessor got COVID, he had to get helicoptered
to Walter Reed Medical Center. He was severely
ill. Thankfully, he recovered well. I got COVID.
I worked from upstairs of the White House and the
office is upstairs. And for the five day period,
the difference is vaccinations, of
course, but also three new tools free
to all and widely available. You don't need to
be president to get these tools to use for your
defense. Right. Here's the bottom line.
Speaker 1: The point here is really to
talk about vaccines. Right. The argument
that Joe Biden is making is Trump wasn't
vaccinated and he had a really serious case. I
am vaccinated and I had a very mild case. Now,
these are not really great arguments. There's
a bunch of different things. Number one,
Biden physically seems healthier than Trump.
I mean, let's be honest. We know Trump's not
really six 3 to 39. Trump is is obese. It's
very unhealthy diet generally. Okay. So that
predisposes Trump to have a more serious case
than Biden, first and foremost. Secondly,
these are different variants. And I am not
making I don't have the latest numbers as
to whether but five, the current variant in
terms of hospitalization, risk or whatever. And
then you have to account for the fact that, yes,
there could be a different hospitalization risk,
but when vaccinated, what is the net likelihood
of being hospitalized now versus back when? TRUMP
There's all of this different stuff. What's
funny about it is Biden just wants to make
the point that thanks to vaccines, he had a mild
case compared to Trump's serious case. But the
funny thing is that it comes off as, again, Trump
just wants to be the alpha and the best and the
strongest at absolutely everything. And it seems
like Biden is kind of ribbing him and, you know,
that it triggers Trump very, very badly. Now, the
third layer that's really funny is Sean HANNITY
then pops up out of nowhere. To then run cover
for Trump about okay, Trump went to Walter Reed,
but that was a much stronger strain. And again,
this is all B.S. It's all a penis size contest,
but everybody's playing their role and
HANNITY pops up as the Trump defender.
Speaker 3: I had to evoke the uniter that he
is his favorite subject, Donald Trump. Right.
Here's the bottom line. When my predecessor
got COVID, he had to get helicoptered to Walter
Reed Medical Center. He was severely ill.
Thankfully, he recovered. When I got COVID,
I work from upstairs in the White House and the
offices upstairs and for the five day period.
The difference is vaccinations, of course. Now,
what Joe failed to mention is the current variant,
which is a five, the dominant variant of Macron
is much, much weaker than the original strain
that infected then-President Trump.
Speaker 1: Right. Don't think for a
second that Biden is any better,
stronger, smarter, faster, nicer,
more intelligent, whatever than Trump. Trump
got hit with a hard variant per virologist. Sean
HANNITY Where is Biden? Got a weak variant and was
vaccinated, I guess, to some degree. HANNITY is
kind of saying that the vaccines work. So anyway,
it's just all a pissing match. It really is. But
something about it I found actually pretty funny.
Joe Biden is back. We're all glad to see that